i am in my office in los angeles where i
live most of the time if i'm not in new
york
oh okay and i don't know if you're on
our guest at trutel edge force here
uh daisy ridley do you know
hey there hey well i you know i i
haven't met them uh formally but
actually um daisy and i worked together
on a star wars film i don't
i don't know that she would remember she
didn't she doesn't look like she could
imagine
no she didn't recognize me when we
worked together but um
we did and i think i have a picture no i
i have a picture i think we've got a
picture this is you
and daisy in star wars right right in
the background i'm in the background in
the white
that's me and um is is prince william
prince william is the other trooper
no because it's interesting a lot of
duty uh vicki mcclure here she was
talking about
she does a thing with the cast members
where she reads the scripts and then
winds them up about things that are
going to happen to their character
because they haven't read them
and apparently you did a similar thing
with aaron paul in breaking bad
aaron paul was supposed to only be in
the first season of breaking bad
my character's introduction to street
level
uh drug dealing and so they were going
to kill him off in the fourth or fifth
episode and i kept reading and and
telling him
oh man you know one of the best things
that any actor can do in cinema
is a good death scene and boy you've got
a great one coming up
oh so good
because you worked with uh aaron paul
yeah yeah
yeah on triple nine and uh he's
fantastic yeah you know it was
amazing i couldn't work out we were in
atlanta and i couldn't work out why
everybody was calling him [ __ ] because
it was before i'd seen
breaking bad you're just
you're just thinking that's very rude
he seems all right
you